aujourd'hui le autorités l'assurance des
élections auxquelles institution chargée
de préparer et d'organiser les élections
et agit donc dans les délais à l'instant
où nous échangeons le traité national
des élections vient de terminer donc
l'enregistrement des électeurs
nous sommes actuellement dans une phase
de gestion des réclamations et du
contentieux le présent la république
vient de signer deux décrets l'un
convoquant le corps électoral
pour le 27 décembre 2020 ce qui
correspondrait donc au premier tour des
élections
et puis le second décret dont qui fixe
le découpage électoral le présent la
république le gouvernement nous tenons
au respect des délais constitutionnels
évidemment nous essayons avec tous les
partenaires du pays qui sont présents
nous essayons de créer les conditions
d'appuyer nos autorités nationales des
élections à obtenir les conditions
d'organiser des élections crédibles
transparentes au résultat irréprochable
et sa sécurisation de faire